email cory booker initially disseminated
we're already cleared for release but
tonight he released more emails that
were not cleared to try to right the
wrong of the stunt to earlier today and
they should have remained confidential
joining me now for reaction saw
Weisenberger he's on vacation i'm glad
you came back saw former deputy
independent counsel the bill clinton
whitewater investigations and scott
Bouldin a democratic strategist attorney
and always spartacus to me put my
picture up there and all the things that
you get for his bed right all right what
do you make of today well i think
there's a lot of theatrics but let's be
real clear he violated the the the
clearance issue on wednesday because he
used the document to cross-examine
Cavanaugh and so whether he knew it was
cleared or not cleared the bottom line
is why were these documents marked
confidential I mean if you look at the
documents that they use there was no
personnel there was no national security
interest that's why the Dems were
complaining about one they had a
document dump and many of these have
been withheld by the Bush lawyers and
yet if you look at them
there's nothing confidential about them
at all and that's fundamentally wrong
what do the Republicans want to hide
what they don't they want the Democrats
to see what don't they want America to
see about the Kavanagh us all this is
what Cooper Anderson Cooper tonight
asked Cory Booker about this whole thing
I'm Spartacus when the emails were
released and cleared earlier in the day
let's watch it was that just a stunt
well I mean the amusing thing about that
is what corn and first said is he
threatened me threatened me with
expulsion so according to Cornyn's rules
it's a lot of talk a lot of bluster
right now I am breaking the rule but I
was raised and taught that the unjust
law you almost have an obligation to
stand against it last night I broke the
rules before they even that and then
they scrambled to release the document
but I continued to release documents I
released 20 so far that they have not
clear I am breaking the rules I am
breaking a sham rules so what's the
point here what is the point of this I
mean you've been around you've seen how
these things go down
I mean Ruth Bader Ginsburg's documents
from when she was at the ACLU were not
even requested I don't believe by anyone
not saw it not released what's going on
here with the quarry Spartacus moment
well he's just incredibly brave Laura I
can't really fathom why you're so
cynical he's just Gandhi and Martin
Luther King rolled into one I think a
couple of things are going on here
number one he's running for president as
several people have pointed out and he
wants to be a hero to the loonie the
loonie left Democratic base which is
which is just as wacky as some of the
people on the Republican right okay I'm
sorry I didn't mean the quasi loony
Democratic left-wing base okay so and
the other thing is I mean it's the whole
thing is a farce it's theater and it's
trying to find that gotcha moment they
know they don't have the votes to the
feet Brett Kavanaugh they know not only
is the Acela candidate but he has
probably the most extensive written
record of anybody who's ever been
nominated a clue including they have a
video every speech he's given in the
last 12 years at every Law School so
they're looking for the gotcha moment
and and that's what's going on and it's
it's sad it is a spectacle and it's
pathetic and I hope it hurts them there
was one moment very brief from Kamala
Harris where she referenced the
Constitution and in an interesting way
let's watch it means rights that are
protected by the Constitution even if
they're not specifically mentioned in
the Constitution so they're not in that
book that you carry the book that you
can't I mean it's just kind of a
Cavalier reference again another well I
don't think it's cavalier I think you
there was a part of that video that
before that that should have been led up
to that because I can't tell exactly
what she was my point is it's all in
auditioning for 2020 all of them pretty
much either have said they're not going
to vote they've already said they're not
going to vote most of them for him but
they've already said he's going to be
confirmed
what over the documents then because of
if it's the most documented paper trail
we've had of anomaly then turn it over
then let the American people know I
don't think the Democrats think they can
stop him but I do think they want to
flesh out where he is and because of his
paper trail
the Republicans are hiding these
documents put the documents out there
and let America judge and let the
Democrats cross-examining money what are
the Republicans so afraid of yeah I
think what's the way the Democrats are
afraid of the fact that they have this
guy up there is one of the smart I've
known for thirty years
full disclosure one of the smartest
lawyers in America probably in America
but he should be like everyone else he
is hundreds of opinions they're all
available that's the most out of nothing
not running for the White House White
House documents let us see them but so
you think a staff secretary is actually
yeah he's working for a boss all right
we're out of time gentlemen thank you so
much